welcome everyone this is part four in
our series on analysis methods in nlp
we're going to be talking about probing
this is the first of the two structural
evaluation methods that we're going to
consider
it's time to get really introspective
about what our models are doing
here's an overview of the probing idea
the core thing is that
we're going to use supervised models
those are the probe models to determine
what's latently encoded in the hidden
representations of our target models
this is often applied in the context of
bertology which would be like i have
bert as a pre-trained artifact and i
would like to understand the nature of
its hidden representations what do they
latently encode and for that you might
use pro models
probink as you will see can be a source
of really valuable and interesting
insights but we do need to proceed with
caution on two major issues here first a
very powerful probe model since it is a
supervised model might lead you to see
things that aren't really in your target
model but rather just things that your
probe model has learned
and you might therefore over diagnose
latent information in your target model
when in fact it's all being stored in
the probe and i'm going to offer you a
technique for navigating around that
shoe
the second one is that probes cannot
tell us about whether the information
that we identify
has any causal relationship with the
target model's behavior it will be very
tempting for you to say oh i have
discovered that this representation
layer includes
part of speech information and you might
therefore conclude that part of speech
information is important for whatever
task you have set but we can't actually
make that inference it could be that the
part of speech information is simply
latently encoded but not actually
especially relevant to your model's
input output behavior
final section of this slideshow i'm
going to just talk briefly about
unsupervised probes which seem to
address this first problem here that the
probe model might actually be the thing
that's encoding all of this information
that we claim to have discovered
and then when we talk about feature
attribution methods we'll get closer to
being able to address some of these
causal questions
let's begin with the core method for
probing and just because this is a
typical framing of these ideas i've got
depicted here what you might think of as
a kind of generic transformer based
model where we have three layers with
all these blocks these maybe are the
output representations from each of the
transformer blocks and you can see that
i've got an input sequence coming in
here and the idea would be that we could
pick some hidden representation in this
model like this middle one h here and
decide that we're going to fit
a small linear model presumably on that
hidden representation
and see whether we can figure out
whether that representation encodes some
information about some task that we care
about so for example if you wanted to
figure out whether sentiment or lexical
entailment was encoded at that point
you'd need a label data set for
sentiment or entailment
and then you would fit the probe model
on this representation and use that to
determine the extent to which that
information is encoded there
this depiction is a little bit poetical
so it's worth just walking through
mechanically what you'd actually be
doing you would use this bert model and
process different examples like for the
sequence here and get an output
representation which should be paired
with some task label
and you would repeatedly do that for
different inputs you're essentially
using this bert model as an engine for
creating representations that will
become your feature representation
matrix x paired with your labels y and
it is this model that will be the basis
for your linear probe model this small
linear model as i've identified it here
so you're kind of using bird as an
engine to create a data set that is then
the input to a supervised learning
problem another perspective would be
that you're kind of using frozen
parameters in this case
and fitting a model on top of them it's
just that instead of picking an output
point you pick possibly
one of the internal representations
and this is very general and in fact the
most often when you read without probes
in the literature they're actually
sequence problems like part of speech
tagging or named entity recognition and
therefore you might use an entire layer
or even a set of layers as the basis for
your probe model
now you can hear in my description there
that there is a kind of interesting
judgment call that you're making about
whether you are probing or simply
learning a new model right probes in the
sense that i just presented them
are supervised models whose inputs are
frozen parameters of the models that
we're probing our target models right
this is hard to distinguish from simply
fitting a supervised model as usual with
some particular choice of featurization
as a result of this it is essentially a
foregone conclusion that at least some
of the information that we identify with
our probe is actually stored in the
probe model parameters and it's just
that we've provided useful input
features that allow this probe to be
successful and that's the sense in which
the inputs are latently encoding this
information but with the probe we have
not determined that it is truly latently
there but rather that it's accepting a
stepping stone toward a model that could
be successful at this is conceived of as
a supervised learning test so those are
important distinctions to keep in mind
as a result of this more powerful probes
like deep neural networks
might find more information than simple
linear models but that's not because
they're able to tease out more
information from the representations
themselves but rather because the pro
model has now has so much more capacity
for storing information about the task
that you're probing for
so there are a bunch of different
judgment calls here and that's difficult
a very productive entry into this space
is this really lovely paper from hewitt
and the 2019 where they introduced the
notion of a control task and the
corresponding metric of probe
selectivity so here's the idea a control
task will be some random task with the
same input output structure as the
target test that we want to use for our
probing
like for example for word sense
classification you might have words
assigned random fixed word senses
independent of their context or for part
of speech tagging instead of using the
actual part of speech tags you might
randomly assign words to fixed tags from
the same tag space
or for parsing it get a little bit more
nuanced but you might have some edge
assignment strategies that you kind of
use semi-randomly to link different
pairs of words into a kind of pseudo
parse and that would serve as a control
task for trying to surface latent actual
parsing information
so those are control tasks and then
selectivity is simply the difference
between your probe performance on the
task and your identical probe model
structure
on these control tasks
and uh hewitt and leon use this to tease
out what i think is a pretty clear
intuition which is that as you get more
powerful probes they simply become less
selective so along the x-axis here we
have mlp hidden units so we have model
complexity from left to right where we
have very complicated powerful models at
the right hand side
and here we have accuracy
and we're measuring our control task in
red
and our actual probe task in this light
blue here and selectivity is the
difference between those two so you can
see for example that the very weak
models the two the ones with two hidden
units have very high selectivity whereas
by the time i have this very powerful
mlp with lots of hidden units
selectivity has gone almost to zero and
it's very hard to say that you've
uncovered any latent information because
even
the control task is fully solvable with
a model that has this much capacity
so i think what this is pushing us
toward is always having control tasks as
part of the picture and always reporting
selectivity so that we can control for
the complexity of the probe model itself
that's an important and easy practical
step that will give you a clearer
picture of what you've actually surfaced
with your probe
that's the first issue the second issue
is just something that you should keep
in mind as a theoretical fact about
probing which is that it is
fundamentally limited in the sense that
it cannot tell you that the information
you discover has any causal impact on
the model's input output behavior to
illustrate that i'm just going to show
you a simple example that kind of proves
this
so imagine over here on the left i have
a simple model that's going to take in
three integers
and sum them so the output here will be
the sum of three integers like if i put
in one two three it will output six and
it does that by representing each one of
those integers as the single dimensional
vector that just is that integer and
then we have a whole bunch of
transformer like model parameters dense
connections here that will lead us
finally to the output layer
right so you can easily imagine that you
probe this position l1 here and you find
that it computes x plus y
which might be starting to reveal for
you that there's some kind of tree
structure to this model even though it
was densely connected it has learned a
structured solution to the problem and
you might probe l2 and find that it
computes z
and that would really lead you to the
thing to think that you've got a kind of
interesting tree structure with
constituents for this addition problem
and that's certainly suggestive however
here is an example of a model that shows
that neither l1 nor l2 has anything to
do with the model's output predictions
it is entirely that middle state that
tells the complete story about the
output
i'll leave you to work through the
details if you choose to but a shortcut
wait to see that is that the final
parameters that take us from these
output representations to the
predictions have zeroed out the first
and third positions leaving only the
second one as having any kind of causal
efficacy
even though in this model if you probe
you do indeed find that it looks like
those representations perfectly encode
these two pieces of information
that's a dramatic uh and clear simple
illustration of how a probe could get
divorced from the actual causal behavior
of the model again something that's
worth keeping in mind
and finally to close this out of course
for that first problem about
distinguishing between
probe capacity and actually latent
latently encoded information
one response to that that's developing
in the literature now is to develop
unsupervised probes these would be
models like these that seek to find
in actual facts about the model with no
additional supervision the latent
information that we hope to find and
this would come from simply simply doing
linear transformations of the parameters
and measuring distance between
parameters as a way of getting a sense
for what's actually there without the
complications that come from having this
additional supervised probe model
and finally for much more information
about probes and what we think they've
we've learned from them and what they
can tell us i encourage you to check out
this paper by rogers at all a primer on
bertology it has a large an interesting
subsection entirely devoted to what
probes have told us certainly worth a
look and a great overview of the space
you